IN RELEASING CONCLUSIONS WITHOUT
TELLING YOU HOW THEY GOT THERE.
CONGRESSMAN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR COMING ON TONIGHT.
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: AND YOU THOUGHT
DIGITAL WAS FOREVER, THAT'S WHAT
COMES TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IN THE MIDDLE OF A SCANDAL.
THE FBI NOW SAYS IT LOST
THOUSANDS, SOMEHOW, OF TEXT
MESSAGES BETWEEN PETER STRZOK
AND LISA PAGE RELEVANT TO THE
CONVERSATION WE'RE HAVING
TONIGHT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP JUST REACTED TO
THOSE MISSING MESSAGES JUST
MOMENTS AGO.
HERE'S PART OF WHAT HE SAID.
>> I DO WORRY WHEN I LOOK AT ALL
OF THE THINGS THAT YOU PEOPLE
YOU KNOW, THE FIVE MONTHS WORTH
OF MISSING TEXTS.
THAT'S A LOT OF MISSING TEXTS,
AND AS I SAID YESTERDAY, THAT'S
PRIMETIME.
SO YOU JUST SORT OF LOOK AT THAT
AND SAY, WHAT'S GOING ON?
YOU DO SORT OF LOOK AT CERTAIN
TEXTS WHERE THEY TALK ABOUT
INSURANCE POLICIES OR INSURANCE
WHERE THEY SAY THEY KIND OF
THINGS THEY'RE SAYING,
YOU'VE GOT TO BE CONCERNED.
COMMUNICATIONS CENTRAL TO AN
INVESTIGATION.
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER HOW 24,000
EMAILS WERE ACCIDENTALLY DELETED
SOMEHOW, THAT HILLARY CLINTON'S
DELETED EMAILS.
TOM, MY IMPRESSION WAS, AND OUR
CYBER SECURITY GUYS ARE ALWAYS
SAYING, IF YOU WRITE IT DOWN
DIGITALLY, IT NEVER GOES AWAY.
WHY IS THAT NOT TRUE FOR FEDERAL
DOCUMENTS IN THESE
INVESTIGATIONS?
>> IT IS ONLY TRUE IF IT IS
CONVENIENT TO WITHHOLD
INFORMATION FROM INVESTIGATORS
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IN THE CASE OF LOIS LERNER, THEY
TOLD US, WE CAN KEEP SOME OF HER
EMAILS.
IT TURNS OUT, THERE WERE BACKUP
TAPES, WE ENDED UP GETTING A LOT
WELL, THERE'S NOTHING TO GIVE
YOU.
TURNS OUT, SHE HAD THEM ALL,
TRIED TO DELETE HALF OF THEM,
AND WE NOW ARE GETTING EMAILS
THAT SHE DELETED OR OTHERWISE
HATED.
THIS IS JUST A MATTER OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT GOING IN AND
FINDING IT WHERE IT IS HIDDEN.
IF I WERE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
OF THE UNITED STATES, IT WOULD
BE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT THE
FBI DID HERE AND I WOULD SEND IN
INDEPENDENT LAW ENFORCEMENT LIKE
THE U.S. MARSHALS TO SECURE AND
RECOVER THIS EVIDENCE.
>> Tucker: I AM CONCERNED.
THESE ARE NOT FAVOR IS THEY ARE
ASKING, IF YOU ARE INVESTIGATING
SOMETHING OR FILING UNDER
THE FREEDOM OF INFORMATION ACT,
YOU HAVE A LEGAL RIGHT TO THESE
DOCUMENTS.
IF THE GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRAT LIE
IF THE GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRAT LIS
TO HER WITHHOLD SOME, WHAT IS
THE PENALTY?
>> COULD BE OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE, OBSTRUCTION OF
CONGRESS, OBSTRUCTION OF
GOVERNMENT PROPERTY --
>> Tucker: ARE CHARGES THAT
ARE BROUGHT ON THESE GROUNDS?
>> THEY ARE IF YOU'RE NOT
HILLARY CLINTON.
>> Tucker: ARE THEY WHERE T
>> Tucker: ARE THEY WHERE E
>> Tucker: ARE THEY WHERE Y
>> Tucker: ARE THEY WHERE A
>> Tucker: ARE THEY WHERE E
IN THE HILLARY CLINTON CASE ARE
THE LOWEST LERNER CASE?
>> NO.
>> Tucker: I CONFESS I'M NOT
AN EXPERT IN DIGITAL QUESTIONS,
DIGITAL QUESTIONS WORK, WHAT YOU
THINK THE TRUTH IS?
>> I THINK MAYBE THERE WAS A
TECHNICAL GLITCH BUT LITTLE
INTEREST IN RESOLVING IT AND
LITTLE INTEREST IN RESOLVING IT
STILL.
INTEREST.
AND THIS IS WHY WE NEED LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND CONGRESS OUGHT
TO STARTED TO AN INQUIRY AS
WELL.
THESE TEXT MESSAGES ABOUT THE
ACTIVITIES OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WHO HAVE BEEN
IMPLICATED IN MASSIVE ABUSES OF
POWER, HAVE RUINED THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION TERMS OF ITS
CREDIBILITY, AND THIS ISN'T --
THIS IS ABOUT THE MILLER
INVESTIGATION.
PETER STRZOK AT THE CENTER OF
THIS, THE KEY INVESTIGATOR IN
THE RUSSIAN CONCLUSION
INVESTIGATION.
WHO KNOWS WHAT EVIDENCE HE HAS
TAINTED.
I THINK THERE IS THIS RACE GOING
INTERVIEWED BEFORE THIS MEMO
COMES OUT AND BEFORE MORE TEXT
MESSAGES COME OUT THAT FURTHER
UNDERMINE HIS ALREADY REALLY LOW
QUALITY INVESTIGATION.
SHOW.
>> CLICKED HIS HEELS THREE